En este video vamos a presentar la idea de
presión parcial debida a los gases ideales. Y para
pensar en ella, vamos a imaginar algún tipo de
contenedor, el cual no tiene sólo un tipo de gas,
tiene más de uno. Así que digamos que tenemos el
gas 1 en color blanco. Obviamente no lo estamos
dibujando a escala, sólo estas moléculas de gas
que se están moviendo. Por acá tenemos el gas 2
en color amarillo, y también tenemos el gas 3 en
color azul. Resulta que se ha podido observar que
la presión total de este sistema, que puedes
imaginar que se está ejerciendo en el interior
de esta pared, o si colocamos cualquier cosa
dentro de este contenedor, la presión, es decir,
la fuerza por área que se ejerce sobre esa cosa,
es igual a la suma de las presiones que aporta
cada uno de estos gases o la presión que ejercería
cada gas por sí solo. Así que esto será igual a la
presión parcial del gas 1 más la presión parcial
debida al gas 2 más la presión parcial debida al
gas 3. Y esto tiene mucho sentido matemático
a partir de la Ley de los gases ideales que
hemos visto antes. Recuerda: la Ley de los gases
ideales nos dice que la presión por el volumen
es igual al número de moles por la constante de
los gases ideales por la temperatura [PV = nRT].
Por lo tanto, si quieres despejar la presión
por aquí, entonces dividiremos de ambos lados
por el volumen, y obtendremos que la presión
es igual a nRT entre el volumen. Por lo tanto,
podemos expresar ambos lados de esta ecuación
de esta forma: la presión total será igual al
número total de moles, n total, por la constante
de los gases ideales por la temperatura en Kelvin,
todo esto dividido entre el volumen del
contenedor, y esto será igual a... bueno,
la presión debida al gas 1 será igual al número
de moles del gas 1 por la constante de los gases
ideales por la temperatura. La temperatura no va a
ser distinta para cada gas, ¿cierto? Suponemos que
todo está en el mismo ambiente, dividido entre el
volumen, y una vez más: el volumen será el mismo,
ya que todos los gases están en el mismo
contenedor. A eso le sumaremos la cantidad
de moles del segundo gas por la constante de los
gases ideales que, de nuevo, va a ser la misma
para todos los gases, por la temperatura entre el
volumen. Y a esto le sumaremos el número de moles
del tercer gas por la constante de los gases
ideales por la temperatura entre el volumen.
Ahora bien, esta vez tenemos tres gases aquí,
pero claramente podremos seguir agregando y
agregando más gases a este contenedor. Y, bueno,
cuando observamos esto de forma matemática,
podemos ver que en la parte derecha podemos
factorizar RT / V, y si hacemos eso vamos a
obtener n₁ + n₂ + n₃, esto entre paréntesis por
RT / V- Y esto de aquí es exactamente lo mismo
que el número total de moles. Si pensamos en el
número de moles del primer gas más el número de
moldes del segundo gas más el número de moles
del tercer gas, eso nos dará el número total de
moles de gas que tenemos en el contenedor. Así que
esto tiene mucho sentido matemática y lógicamente;
y podemos usar estas ideas matemáticas para
responder otras preguntas o proponer otras
formas de pensar en esto. Por ejemplo, digamos que
sabemos que la presión total en nuestro contenedor
debida a todos los gases es de 4 atmósferas, y
digamos que también sabemos que el número total
de moles en el contenedor es igual a 8 moles, y
digamos que también sabemos que el número de moles
del tercer gas es igual a 2 moles. ¿Podemos usar
esta información para encontrar la presión parcial
debida al tercer gas? Pausa el video y piénsalo.
Bueno, una forma de resolverlo es pensar que la
presión parcial ejercida por el tercer gas entre
la presión total será igual al número de moles
del tercer gas por la constante de los gases
ideales por la temperatura entre el volumen,
mientras que la presión total será igual a esta
expresión, es decir, al número total de moles por
la constante de los gases ideales por la misma
temperatura, porque, recuerda, todo está en el
mismo ambiente dividido entre el mismo volumen,
ya que están en el mismo contenedor. Entonces
podemos ver claramente que RT / V está tanto en
el numerador como en el denominador, así que se
cancelarán y obtendremos que la presión parcial
debida al tercer gas entre la presión total es
igual al número de moles del tercer gas entre
el número de moles totales. Y esta cantidad que
tenemos aquí se le conoce como la fracción molar.
Déjame anotarla: fracción molar, y podemos ver que
la fracción molar nos puede ayudar a encontrar la
presión parcial. Así que para este ejemplo sólo
necesitaremos sustituir los valores. Sabemos que
la presión total es 4, sabemos que el número total
de moles es 8 y sabemos que el número de moles del
tercer gas es 2. Y ahora podemos resolver: sabemos
que la presión parcial del tercer gas entre 4
= 2 / 8, 2/8 es lo mismo que ¼. Por lo tanto,
podemos buscar el patrón o simplemente multiplicar
ambos lados por 4 para encontrar la presión
parcial debida al tercer gas, que será igual
a 1, y como estamos trabajando con atmósferas
como unidades para la presión total, entonces
será también 1 atmósfera. Y hemos acabado.